hello and welcome to this video a little
bit different video today yeah I'm going
to ask you your opinion about something
um in the next week this means starting
January 18th I'm going to do something
form for the reddit supper forum for
chess yeah they wanted to start
something for 2016 called opening of the
week so there's an opening featured
every week and there's one contributor
in the forum is going to do something or
present something about a particular
opening opening line opening structure
and yeah I um wanted to get to do one of
the initial weeks maybe I'll do more
later but this is about the week
starting January 18th and on the first
feature actually is running this week
bye bye kingscrusher he's doing the
Sicilian grown pre-attack and he got to
that subject by asking the guys on on
the reddit forum what they wanted to see
just making a pole so I'm going to do
the same thing using the same page that
he did some kind of borrowing his idea
so um you're able to vote what opening
I'm going to present or going to go to
feature and I'm going to give you a
quick overview what it is I was thinking
I've got 77 possible options so there's
some variety their first option is an
overview of the Dutch Leningrad what is
that so this is dying deform f5 g3
Knight f6 Bishop g2 g6 it's not i'm not
going to just feature this particular
water but in general the set up with the
Dutch with g6 so the Leningrad is
defined by this this kind of
this kind of structure um this is the
first possible option second option is
something that starts really early the
Larsen opening 1 B 3 i'm going to give
an overview about this opening yeah it's
not specifically meant for for one side
it just it's what is this opening about
what our imported lines if you want to
play it what do you have to look at what
what do you have to know it's a it's
something general also about what plans
are featured and so on it's not not
meant to be a complete repertoire any
signal that it's just a additional
information about about the opening it's
like reading a very thorough let's say
Wikipedia tickle article but just in
video form okay this is a second option
B 3 third option on the arguably main
line of the Queens gambit declined the
counter Cooper variation there are
various move water spent going to go for
one popsugar move order and b6 this is
the tar to cover this is one of the most
respected answers to one deform it has
been heavily featured in World
Championship matches since the other 19
1960s 1970s yeah favorite option of
karpovsky sparrow has played it a lot
you've got crumbs egg on the black side
cards and every world champion has
played this opening so on if you want
yet journey back into her chest classics
and learn more about this very classical
opening this is your choice the fourth
choice is an e forse opening and this is
a French advance it's also an important
line in the French and it will catch and
over you what what black can do what I
can do a general overview of that of
that line that could be used for you for
useful for you for for both sides
actually and also to learn something
about ideas in the French
the next option is the Sicilian
accelerated dragon Roxy mind which
arises after this this is the pure
Sicilian move order the maroc see bind
however in this form and I'm only going
to feature the maroc see with g6 so this
is this particular setup um this is also
often reached by other move orders for
example I have gotten that on the board
very often in in this way oops somehow
that board is it's making issues in this
kind of Wayne is also very much possible
so one subject that had know quite a bit
about um the 61 the 61 is not a
particular line but this will be an
overview if you are going to vote for
that this will be an overview for the
black side I can switch sides if you
want an overview for the black side like
quick simple recipes what to do if white
is not playing eform or d 4 or c4 on 93
yeah everything else was that so what
what what is what is it that you should
do if they go g4 or before or be 3 or 93
or f wire then somewhat rare obscure
lines we're going to make a couple of
videos to show um easy to handle recipes
against those moves yeah it's a maybe
not entirely in the spirit of a
particular opening of the week but I
think if that is chosen it's quite
useful for you to know what to do
against the against the rambles I mean I
will everybody talk about stuff like a
three and h3 and whatever but this is
quite easy to handle okay and the
seventh one
seventh option is the Kings Indian
attack going to switch them but again
this will be an overview about the Kings
Indian attack an opening that can arise
Ryan Knight f3 g3 Bishop g2 g3 and so on
or sometimes also via e form and then
the subsequent d3 yeah this is an
interesting option for for white players
and I will go give an overview about
about this this opening line something
that I sometimes use nowadays and bullet
chest because you can put out the move
so so quickly and automatically still
it's not meant to be like a bullet
repertoire anything it's just what is
this opening all about if white and
place like that with a later d3 wifey
goes for something like that after
having started efore so you've got seven
options please go to that site the straw
poll poor dot polka dots deep mb I'm
sorry I'm going to give you the link in
the in the video and yeah please go
there and vote for what you think is
most interesting and I'm going to yeah
pick the one which has got the most
votes and make videos on that in the
coming week starting January 18th ok
guys thanks for watching and please make
sure to to vote